how old are you
oh i'm 32. are you married you have kids
like what's your
status oh i'm single i'm not having
children
um i purposely did not want to get
married primarily because
um you know quite frankly we all got to
be honest about ourselves about what
we're going to be bringing to
relationships i'm
i'm personally in therapy i have a life
coach and i'm dealing with my own issues
from childhood i can't bring children
into that that's just irresponsible
okay so so what you're saying is you
wanna you wanna have a guy in your life
you wanna have a top shelf man you feel
like you're doing the work on yourself
but you're having a hard time finding it
right
yes it's very difficult to deal with the
um and i and i hate saying this
especially as a woman but
the especially in my community we're
almost approaching an 80
out of wedlock birth rate so you can
imagine the quality of
males that's pumping out and it's
bleeding into other communities as well
so it's so and generally speaking what
happens in the black community ends up
happening everywhere else later on so
it seems like no matter where you're
going you're you're
finding males who have very very little
self-esteem very self very little
self-confidence but they demand that you
be smaller in order to compensate for
their lack of manhood
okay so let me so let me circle back to
you so you've watched my channel for a
while so you know that i
you know tell you guys men are success
objects women are beauty objects
yes how tall are you how much do you
weigh oh um i'm 510
and i'm 162. okay
sounds a little bit heavy to me actually
no um are you all muscle
yeah yeah i i am i kettlebell three
times a week
box four times a week so um if i if i
could show you a picture of me then you
you'd see like i'm not turning the
camera if you're you know
i want to indulge me okay i'm not
comfortable being on camera
in front of a whole bunch of people i'm
a little bit scared i can always send
you my id
so well if you drop it in the private
chat everybody else in private chat's
gonna see it just heads up so
if you're okay with that i'll take a
look at it and i'll comment on that but
that's
that's the most important you know
component that's the one that i find for
the most part women overlook
the most is they're like i want a good
guy i want a guy that's sorted i don't
want to deal with his daddy issues i
don't want to deal with the fact that he
was raised by some of mom and he hasn't
worked on a i don't want to deal
with a wimp i want to be with a man
yeah and then it's like okay well what
do you look like like are you the kind
of woman that's going to attract that
kind of guy because there's guys out
there looking for
beautiful feminine black women right yes
um so okay so i'm not saying this to
kind of brag and i'm not saying this to
kind of boost myself up the usual
comparison i get
is naomi campbell okay so
why are you having a hard time then if
you look like naomi campbell
because when you're looking at so so one
of the
the drawbacks of being quote unquote
pretty or beautiful
is you attract everybody and a lot of
the times what i'm finding is the men
that you would want to speak to
um they're usually they're kind of
i can't quite put my finger on it
there's a there's a particular kind of
confidence that you want in a manner
that you want because you know that he's
i'm just throwing that up on the screen
just in case anybody doesn't know who
naomi campbell is right so this is
this is what we're talking about this is
what you look like yeah
okay yeah i'd be happy to show you my
actual picture if i could show it to you
privately so you could see that i'm not
lying
um but yeah like there's a particular
kind of masculinity that i grew up with
i grew up with a very strong father
um very good relationship with him yeah
he's awesome my dad
i'm daddy's girl till this day where do
you live um i think actually in canada
i'm not
i'm in ontario okay do you live in a big
city like toronto ottawa windsor
i'm in toronto which is another problem
a lot of liberal
men a lot of man buns a lot of you know
skinny jeans and dudes who are
you know it's it's it's a lot more
feminine energy that i'm accustomed to
especially since i come from a very
conservative
west indian background where the men are
men
so what you need to do is you need to
put yourself in an environment where
these top shelf men are
tennis clubs boating clubs yachting
clubs you need to start doing
like find stuff that you're genuinely
interested in that you like doing like
don't just make it up just to put
yourself in a room where there's hot
guys with money that are
well put together and alpha and have a
father and mother and all sort of stuff
but find stuff that you like and start
spending more time doing that and
interacting with people in those
environments um
what do you do for a living oh i do i
have my own company i do business
development
um i also have started a not-for-profit
or i'm working with a not-for-profit
that specializes in working with men who
are victims of sexual abuse
i think that's a huge issue so that's
one of the things that i'm kind of
passionate about
okay so one of the things that i will
say um i don't like it when women get
involved in spaces where men should be
championing
you know resolving the problem right
like i i find a lot of women want to
fix men yeah and build the better beta
which
you know we talked about earlier in the
part of the book and
like women will see
you're kind of at a precipice at an age
because i've said you know women will
overlook
a broke somewhat incompetent
hot guy in his early 20s like like like
she'll look past that
if he's got a plan like if he looks like
he has promise and then his time moves
on it's kind of like a sliding scale
but by the time he's like 40 or so he
could look hot
and he could have a plan but if he's
still broke and doesn't have anything to
show for himself
he's not very valuable in a sexual
marketplace unless it's just for the
alpha c
part of the hypergamy equation right so
like you're trying to starting to
transition from early part to that part
over there
yeah it's you've got one foot in each
bucket
right leaning from one side to the other
and it's very very difficult because my
daddy always told me like he said
ambition is something you can't teach
someone it's just it's just an inherent
it's just it's just something that's
just an intangible thing that's just
kind of
there right so so just to stop you for a
sec just to keep it on point because
because i got a bunch of people waiting
i want to make sure i get through
everybody i mean you can book a call too
right
you know if you want to schedule
coaching for one-on-one that's always
available to everybody but
what i want to say is going back to the
earlier point what you're talking about
here again is
fixing and and building the better beta
like i'm like i'm getting involved in a
nonprofit that you know fixes guys that
have these you know discrepancies and a
passion
like don't buy a busted ass car trying
to fix it
oh no no go and go and go and order
yourself
that that brand new car with all the
treatment that you want because
if you're not married previously married
don't have any kids in tow you say
you're hot
you look like naomi campbell i bet
there's a lot of top shelf men out there
that would line up for a chance to date
you
right so put yourself in that
environment and expose yourself to that
rather than worrying about trying to
build a better beta
yeah so okay so the so the problem is is
that it's not so much the attracting
men with money because that's not an
issue but
as you know money doesn't equal
character
money and character have a it's one
thing if you're dating a guy who doesn't
make a lot of money but if something was
to happen he'll fight for you and he'll
protect you
and it's another thing if you're dating
a guy who makes six figures but he can't
take a punch and he's kind of
he's kind you know i'll say this money
magnifies character so if you're an
if you have a lot of money you're going
to become more of an that's
right
if you're a weak beta you're still going
to be a big ass weak beta with a lot of
money
you're going to start simply right so i
mean
there's a lot of guys like that out
there because toronto is a very liberal
left-leaning city
most of society subscribes to a female
pro first primary social order they want
to bend the knee so they can become less
so she can become more so they'll simp
for girls
you know they'll throw up and that
doesn't turn on women as you've
experienced which is what i'm
what i keep trying to tell you guys and
it's nice that we have some women coming
on you know from time to time to share
some of these experiences but
that's not what they want they want a
guy to lead they want to look up to a
giant they want to follow like
but you have to be a guy that's worthy
of that right
so yeah again back to my point stop
trying to build a better beta
stop you know trying to fix just
put yourself in an environment where
you're exposing yourself to these top
shelf men
and be fastidious with your time and
selective so if the guy's simpy if he's
beta if he doesn't turn you on
next right on okay fair thank you so
much rich
fair enough all right we'll see you
later later
you